No shirt, these forking actors ought to
have their mother-forking mouths washed
out with god-dang soap. Let's forking do this.
Thanks to the extensive research by British gaming
company Buzz Bingo, we can start our list with
Danny McBride at number 10. The curse-counters
over there put McBride’s naughty word film total
at 136 curse words on screen over the course of
his movie career. Again, that’s according to Buzz
Bingo, but if you can’t trust an internet gambling
site to count curse words, who can you trust?
It's not surprising that McBride makes the
list, as he is most well-known for raunchy,
R-rated comedies like Pineapple Express and Tropic
Thunder. McBride even contributed voice acting to
Sausage Party, and we really don’t need to
explain Sausage Party any more than that,
right? Good. His ranking on this list might
have been even higher had his performances
in several HBO shows, including Eastbound and
Down and The Righteous Gemstones, been taken
into consideration. Unfortunately, television
shows weren't counted in this film-focused study.
McBride has become known for
playing pretty horrible characters,
an archetype that likely contributed to him
getting a spot on this lineup. In The Foot
Fist Way, he plays an incompetent Taekwondo
instructor on a mission to meet his idol.
This Is The End sees him as an egotistical actor
who doesn’t get the gravity of what’s going on.
And he plays a lazy, slobbish prince in "Your Highness."
"Where the f--- was that in Green Hornet, huh?
Jonah, you're f---ing sucking b---s. You're an
Academy Award nominated person, you need to
be f---cking selling that s---, dude."
Coming in at number nine is Bradley Cooper,
who has uttered a respectable 142 swear words
over the course of his decades-long career.
Unlike several other actors on this list,
Cooper doesn't appear in any of
the top 10 most swear-heavy films,
nor does he play any of the most
explicit characters in film history.
In recent years, Cooper has become known for
Oscar-winning dramas like A Star Is Born,
American Hustle, and Silver Linings
Playbook. R-rated dramas like these
have likely contributed to Cooper's place
on the list, but the fact that he's never
starred in a Scorsese or a Tarantino
film certainly docks him a few points.
In addition to his featured dramas, Bradley Cooper
also starred in The Hangover and its
two sequels, a series that undoubtedly
contributed a significant number of
curse words to his overall score.
"Alright, what that f---, man? We
gotta get this s--- together, guys!"
Cooper also voiced the crass Rocket Raccoon in
the Guardians of the Galaxy films, but since
Marvel films are almost always PG-13, he wasn't
allowed to go as far as he might have liked.
In fact, Guardians director James Gunn
tweeted that there is unseen footage of
Rocket dropping the f-bomb extensively. Gunn
knew he wouldn't be able to use the footage, but
filmed it nonetheless. If only Marvel would let
more of their films be as explicit as Deadpool,
perhaps Cooper would be higher up on the list.
Like his buddy Danny McBride, Seth Rogen
clinches a spot on the list primarily
because of his work in comedy films.
As number eight, Rogen has dropped a curse
on 143 occasions throughout his career.
As with Bradley Cooper, Rogen isn't in
any of the most explicit films out there,
meaning his swear words have been spread
out over a number of different roles.
Though he has branched out into producing
more recently, Rogen's career kicked off
mainly through stoner comedies. After getting
his start on the teen show Freaks and Geeks,
Rogen starred in raunchy comedies like
Superbad, Knocked Up, and Pineapple Express
"Except if you're a d--- your whole life,
your next shell will be made of s---,
okay? If you're an a-------. you're
gonna come back as a cockroach."
Billy Bob Thornton may not be the first
person you think of in a discussion
about the most explicit actors out there,
but with 100 acting credits to his name,
it's not all that surprising he made the
cut. Thornton is number seven on the list,
having delivered 145 curse
words over the last few decades.
"This is bulls---. Give me one good reason why
I should even consider doing this right now."
"Cuz I let 2000 kids spit in my
f---ing face for your a--, that's why."
While Thornton's character in Bad Santa doesn't
top the list of the most vulgar characters in
film history, his role in the franchise accounts
for many of the swear words in his repertoire.
Despite the crass nature of the role, Thornton
took both films seriously. He told Entertainment
Weekly that swearing is an artform, and that there
needs to be a good reason to curse in every scene.
We'll take it from the master.
As one of the most prolific and
beloved actors working in Hollywood today,
it's somewhat surprising that a Shakespearian
actor like Denzel Washington would have a
spot on this list.Landing at number six,
Washington has recited 183 curse words over the
course of his long and storied career. You might
think Washington knocked out all his curse words
in Training Day, but Denzel has sprinkled in a
few here and there along his career. But let’s
face it: you’re here for the Training Day rants:
"You're lucky that I have more pressing
business. I'd cut your f---ing d--- off
and stick it right up that little
funky a-- of yours, b----."
Wow, um, yeah, we were going to
show another one too, but let’s…
jeez Denzel! Anyway, moving along!
It's not hard to guess why Al Pacino, an
actor most well-known for playing mobsters,
has a spot on this list. With an impressive 255
swear words to his name, Pacino comes in at number
five. While you might think someone as loud and
commanding as Pacino would be a shoo-in for a
Martin Scorsese film, the two only ever worked
together for 2019's Netflix film, The Irishman.
"That f---ing c--------- Kennedy has
got his nose up my a-- everywhere I go."
If you're a big Pacino fan, you might be able to
guess the most profane film he has ever starred
in. According to Buzz Bingo, Pacino's character in
Scarface is the seventh most vulgar character in
cinema history, with 165 swear words under his
belt. In Scarface, Pacino plays Tony Montana,
a Cuban immigrant who assassinates a government
official in order to get a green card.
Tony then becomes a big name in the Miami drug
trade, acquiring money, power, and, of course,
beautiful women like Michelle Pfeiffer.
Interestingly, while the film has curses
peppered throughout its runtime, the film's
most famous line doesn't contain a single swear.
"Say hello to my little friend!"
Comedy legend Adam Sandler comes in at
number four on the list, with Buzz Bingo
claiming he’s dropped a whopping 295 swear
words. A lot of those swear words come
from a single movie: 2019's Uncut Gems.
Sandler's Howard swears 295 times in the
film, and the film itself contains a grand
total of 646 swear words according to the
Buzz Bingo folks. Statistically speaking,
that means that slightly more than 35 out of
every 1,000 words in the film are “bad words”.
"And what f---ing DJ is gonna play his s---?
I know every f---ing DJ in this
town. F--- all you losers."
Uncut Gems became so famous for its swearing
that Netflix actually compiled a video of
every f-bomb dropped in the film, ending
up with more than four minutes of footage.
You might think that Sandler saves the cursing for
his R rated flicks, and his raunchy PG-13’s are
devoid of F-bombs… Well, ladies and gents,
let’s all take a look at Billy Madison:
“If Your dog is lost you don’t look for
an hour and call it quits, you get your
a– out there and find that f—--- dog!”
Lots of viewers might have expected the next
person on this list to be on the very top. When
you think of actors who famously swear a lot,
the great Samuel L. Jackson is probably the
first person who comes to mind. However,
according to Buzz Bingo, Jackson doesn't
actually hold the record for the most
foul-mouthed actor to ever grace the silver
screen. He may have delivered 301 swear words
over the course of his film career, but that
only gets him to number three on the list.
There are probably a few films that come to mind
when you imagine Jackson's most explicit roles,
and there are certainly a number of different
films that contribute to his final swear count.
The most profane character Jackson has ever
played in his career, is, unsurprisingly,
a character in a Quentin Tarantino film. Ordell,
Jackson's character in Jackie Brown, swore 183
times over the course of the film, making him
the fifth most profane character in film history.
When Jimmy Fallon confronted Jackson
with the fact that he actually isn't
the most profane actor in history,
Jackson had the perfect response:
"That's some bull—-. I mean, that's a —
I mean, I mean — no."
Indeed, Jackson has become so synonymous with
swearing that InsiderHook reports the
most famous line in Snakes On A Plane
was actually added after the fact in order
to placate fans who wanted to hear it.
"Enough is enough. I have had it with these
motherf—-ing snakes on this motherf—ing plane.”
That’s the line, right? Is
Monday a curse word yet?
Leonardo DiCaprio may be an actor known
for his impressive crying ability,
but his swearing skills aren't too shabby either.
As the runner-up on the list, DiCaprio's
swear count is a whopping 361 words.
Many of the swear words DiCaprio has uttered come
from Martin Scorsese's The Wolf of Wall Street.
DiCaprio plays Jordan Belfort, a Wall Street
banker who makes a fortune at a young age,
only to be hounded by the FBI for his wild antics
and debauchery. Jordan swears 332 times in the
film, making up a large chunk of DiCaprio's
total swear count. By Buzz Bingo's metric,
Jordan is the most profane character in cinema
history. Unsurprisingly, The Wolf of Wall Street
is also the most vulgar film ever according
to the study, with 715 swear words overall.
"F— you!"
"No, don't f—--- dare throw that f—---
water at me. Don't you f—--- dare."
Because not every swear word DiCaprio has said
comes from The Wolf of Wall Street, there are a
few other films that must contribute to his swear
count. In the Tarantino film Once Upon a Time...In
Hollywood, DiCaprio plays Rick Dalton, a washed-up
Western star struggling to stay relevant.
While the film may contain a
notable amount of swearing,
DiCaprio was reportedly insistent that the
swearing only happen on camera. According
to Fatherly, DiCaprio demanded that
the cast and crew stop swearing on set
to protect his 10 year-old co-star, Julia
Butters. DiCaprio may have played the most
foul-mouthed character in film history, but he
draws the line at swearing around children.
The distinguished honor of the most
foul-mouthed actor in film history
goes to the one and only Jonah Hill, who has
spoken an astounding 376 swear words on screen.
“It’s Bulls—, and I’m sorry.”
Considering the other actors on this list,
this is not actually all that surprising,
as Hill stars alongside DiCaprio in the overly
explicit The Wolf Of Wall Street. In fact,
out of every 1,000 words Hill's character
Donnie speaks, 74 of them are swear words,
making him even more foul-mouthed than
DiCaprio's character proportionally.
While a significant number of swear words in
Hill's overall count come from The Wolf Of Wall
Street, it's not the only curse-heavy movie in
his filmography. When you look at the cold, hard
numbers, Hill's most profane role is his character
Seth in Superbad. Seth is a high schooler on a
mission to score alcohol for a party, and he
swears 152 times over the course of the film.
"Have you actually ever met anyone named McLovin?"
"No! That's why you picked a dumb f---ing name!"
"F--- you."
21 Jump Street, Knocked Up, and This Is
The End are a few other R-rated comedies
in Hill's repertoire that likely
contributed to his winning status.
Though Jackson may have been peeved not
to clinch the number one spot on the list,
Hill was happy enough to accept his flowers. He
took to Instagram to celebrate the achievement,
thanking Martin Scorsese and Sam Jackson
for helping him accomplish such a feat.